dans les rues d'avdivka les habitants
vivent au milieu des ruines et des
bruits d'explosion la ville située dans
la BAN nord de Donetsk est la cible de
nombreux assuss depuis un
mois vous savez ce que je veux dire à
Poutine c'est un salot et je veux dire à
tous ceux qui sont à Don qu'ils sont des
ordures ils ne savent pas où est sur qui
il tire il y a des gens
ici Moscou intensifie ses frappes sur
les position
la ligne de front semble figé depuis
près d'un an l'raine a acté l'échec de
sa contreoffensive entamée en juin
depuis keV volodimir zensk assure que
ses soldats tiennent leur position dans
la
région la Russie perd déjà des soldats
et du matériel près d'avka d'une manière
plus rapide et plus
importantem soutenir leur pression est
très
difficile plus il y a de forces russes
détr PRS plus la situ enemi sera
difficile pour le reste de la
guerre les autorités ukrainiennes
répètent à qui veulent entendre que
l'aide occidentale reste primordiale
pour contrecarer les ambitions russes
réunis à Bruxelles les ministres de la
défense des 27 ont une nouvelle fois
réaffirmé leur soutien à Kief l'Union
européenne a fourni 300000 munitions
d'artillerie à l'Ukraine un chiffre
qu'elle s'est engagé à faire monter
jusqu'à 1 million au printemps prochain
un objectif difficile à tenir pour
certains le million de munitions de sera
pas atteint il faut l'assumer la vraie
question est de savoir si l'objectif
d'un million a jamais été réaliste il y
a eu des voix pour dire qu' 1 million
semble facile à atteindre et que nous
avons l'argent pour mais la production
doit pouvoir suivre une déclaration
toutefois nuancée par le patron de la
diplomatie européenne s'il reconnaît un
objectif ambitieux Joseph Borel explique
tout mettre en œuvre pour que l'Union
tienne sa promesse